I'll think I went welcome back to him
what was going on at best away that's
just a that's just vape it's I miss him
I did not miss you you kept hitting me
putting me down pets alright there we go
what is that noise it's a father I don't
like this I don't dare let get out a
music yeah my pair don't cut Wow buddy
although in it get off that a metal
bucket what should we do with that let's
figure it out yourself you [ __ ] fine
fine you know what I'll do it
I'm scared I don't like this shakiness
whoa it's a knife I can kill people what
Chuck I would never kill that's Ken send
a Mentos candies in this game who would
have thought I pens this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
look at cinnamon tells cam again I'm
just kidding Wow what is this ah sorry
about that brah all right you go first a
photo I don't like this as I god yeah
this period all over this [ __ ] southern
prison cells
I probably shouldn't leave until I find
what I came for
what did I come from exactly I don't
know about this I don't know about me
but I know about you
Clemmy hello what all right let's go
this way I'm sure nothing bad what
happened ah what the [ __ ] did I come
from I came from here ah okay so I have
a bucket of poo let me see here let me
see why the [ __ ] I'm doing here for a
second alright alright where's the fun
Oh Maisie
don't this time I am me all day why hiya
pal
why you gotta wake my nap since
I don't know I don't know by that hey
that's a cap now we don't need to go
through the cap we need to go to no not
you a [ __ ] which one which one was it
I think the third one is it this one yes
what's the way any I bucket get out of
here I need I need I need to put that
there
all right so now we got some of the acid
yeah yeah yeah you're sleeping again
brah
nope all right good day right going down
here three sig no do it matter
whoa now it's surprisingly better than
expected
all right flinch heads I don't want to
sleep Shh heads I'm not touch okay we're
gonna put you that and that is the key
what what what what what Deb's you gotta
get out of here fat what what is going
what it what in the heaven sit either go
oh [ __ ]
Wow this place has got a block turns you
gotta hurry but your slit you're the one
sleeping I'm not sleeping
whoa look at my shaking brow giant
subscribe for this period everyone run
for pants
oh [ __ ] I'm running ah ha ha ha ok ok
we're good stop stop there but Jennifer
it's attacking back the fog keep out of
the blood but that wasn't even in the
book
where's the father amia mega mega don't
that stop no no I gotta go without him
that poor son of a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I'm running I'm running oh [ __ ]
ah shut eyes shut data fire hello
oh wow are you kidding me
oh [ __ ] I got the skills what what the
[ __ ] are you doing in my face Clank
Jason whoa Jennifer what do you know
what she just [ __ ] in my head
Jason okay I get it I got a bookie it
would be my shield but I'm a buck bucks
don't talk shut up okay here we go
I'm shaking like a [ __ ] and like
I want bath salts alright well how do
you watch how to help God with my book
cover my face oh Sh all right doc you
know what's about to come back all right
that shit's a transman don't you okay
hair lesson whoa nice cover
Oh Thank You pence that means a lot to
me why don't you shut up a bit I'm sorry
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ] what
am i doing what am i doing there we go
this no no no no all the buddies go back
that bladder scoffing what stop falling
in my ass out where do I go
what the [ __ ]
what [ __ ] don't wanna fall in my eyes
that doesn't make sense
I don't want to go to sleep oh we're
going in here yes I found myself
abnormal it's trusting overly elaborate
institutions and astonishing
they've been accurate something we lost
we lost the final the door
wha don't worry oh [ __ ] I heard what the
[ __ ] is I he's a brat he said he's
stronger than he looks all right
he's not gonna die from just that all
right so that's this [ __ ] being [ __ ]
over here oh [ __ ] you're left out [ __ ]
all right away no bras I don't know
about this do I gotta take the tunnel
again I don't want to take the top you
[ __ ] haha I didn't touch you how do you
do that that's amazing okay we just
gotta take it easy burchett bras here
just gotta take it [ __ ] easy what
fine we're all fine
okay uh-huh hello mattress okay well oh
we're going in here now all right get it
you have the key right yep this means
it's a loading screen so you know what's
up I like your hat you're not wearing a
hat oh are you what oh that's like a bet
that I am that really nice hat did you
make it yourself
lovely lovely so ask me something now no
I'm not gonna get naked chase your perm
all right let's continue
I gotta find a photo I bet he's there
somewhere I let a [ __ ] open in here
that all right uh-huh I gotta take that
ah make it cozy Nick lovely boxes I
don't like you anymore actually I never
like why would you tell it on a jack Oh
finally we got the [ __ ] Latin geez
[Music]
hey who's crying over there stop paying
up oh it's a puzzle here all right solve
that
I would assume it needs another cog
wheel I don't know what's up with that
bah all right I guess we got to go and
find it and [ __ ] uh-huh
it should be pretty basic stuff you know
what isn't that right lay-oh nice right
there I'm gonna kill you why what why
would you do that I gotta put you here
nice and you calm your tits okay you
calm your down calm down Shh I don't
want to hear it I don't want to hear all
right this looks like a jump scare
simple luck huh
brute force what about you [ __ ] we gotta
find one of those pick locks or whatever
did I come from here yep
ah so there should be a pig clock here
somewhere that I miss probably up the
shelf or some [ __ ] like that oh there's
a cogwheel here and see you my friend
why didn't you tell me about this okay
there you go
I bet you bros were alright do we need
coal no wait that's all we need
it's working bronze that's working
nothing oh it's rubbing my nipples oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ] I was stuck
there well I still need that picklock
thing as a yeah I have this knife in
case of someone's wanted to [ __ ] with me
okay so we got Shh ah okay simple Locker
well I might have ate it
Byron step o'clock I'll never tell they
worry that I'll never say a well I am
what about ah ah [ __ ] no but says it
what I did how I did it why did I do
this
okay I got it I got it
kids got it we melt the bucket we melt
the crowbar
whoa no bucket now it's too hot
microboy what did I make a chump of
melted metal well whadya [ __ ] now
it's my lucky day huh all right cool
that was pretty cool wasn't it cool you
didn't think that was cool that was a
cool puzzle though is he behind me where
whoa whoa whoa everyone calm down
and what's the table table what the [ __ ]
are you damn oh damn oh damn oh protect
my table y'all never will take shut up
just do it I don't know about this
brother too big to fit in the lock
that's why she's fat happy shop stop
dancing too big to fit the lot huh well
I got some trick up my dick I mean sleep
yep dick jokes best joke I ever made all
right how do we shake then I don't
[ __ ] know these things
you take the song ah is that it
Gazza
what shards of network that is a great
puzzle man ladies and gentlemen for us
present shows bronze and brass
brozen bravados how are they all right
finally we can go here I hope all right
I'm using you as a shield oh I do not
want to go it hey brother
hope you enjoyed this episode please
leave a like and favorite if you did and
subscribe to come abroad today and I
will see you next stay awesome
[Music]
No